an iconic vegas character could soon
disappear after a cease and desist
letter was sent out for any elvis
representation that's right the company
that licenses elvis presley merchandise
is behind it now local wedding chapel
officials say this would be a big hit to
the industry
it would really not just hurt our small
business it would hurt the marriage
tourism in general melody willis
williams runs two wedding chapels in las
vegas and says elvis themes are always
popular demands i really think the
wedding industry has helped keep elvis
and his name alive to a generation of
people that never got to see him this
business owner says she was one of
several around the valley who recently
received this letter from authentic
brands group it states it is the company
that licenses elvis presley and is
asking for a seasoned assist for the
name likeness and image of the singer
our may 2022 citizen of the month jesse
garan is a full-time elvis impersonator
for over 30 years and recently named
citizen of the month in las vegas he
says this letter is a death sentence for
him and others in the industry you see
one more person on the unemployment line
this is all i've ever done this is what
we do i got the best job in the world
the vegas wedding chamber issued this
statement saying in part it is
especially concerning that las vegas
chapels and impersonators are being
targeted as so many people's livelihood
depends on these weddings using his
image
event planners say they are getting
ready for any legal fight coming down
the pipeline we have started a legal
process to see what we can do ultimately
it's my hope to join the chapels
together and be a united front for this
because i know how important it is to
them as well
[Music]
well i reached out to authentic brands
group for comment and i'm still waiting
for a response now we should also
mention the biopic film elvis will be
released next month